es wäre eine katastrophe für die
menschheit das aussterben der bienen 70
prozent der wichtigsten nutzpflanzen
werden von ihnen bestäubt ohne sie
würden die weltweiten ernten einbrechen
genau das droht der menschheit zur zeit
jetzt das thema eigentlich zum science
fiction
das ist schon ein bisschen kurios immer
mehr imker ziehen mit ihren
bienenvölkern in die städte denn dort
gibt es inzwischen in parks und auf
balkonen eine größere pflanzenvielfalt
als auf dem land und noch etwas ist
ziemlich schlimm auf dem land droht den
bienen der tod eine aktuelle studie des
eu wissenschafts netzwerkes ea sec hat
es jetzt bestätigt pestizide sind für
das bienensterben verantwortlich nicht
alleine aber maßgeblich pestizide sind
gifte die gegen tierische
pflanzenschädlinge ausgebracht werden im
april und mai 2008 fand eine katastrophe
in deutschland statt nachdem dort die
maissaat mit dem pestizid clothianidin
gebeizten und gesät wurde starben in
süddeutschland 11.500 bienenvölker ohne
solche pestizide sind die riesigen
mais-monokulturen kaum überlebensfähig
sie werden vom rat rom zerfressen
die gifte gegen den wurm töten aber auch
die bienenvölker zudem schwächen die
riesigen monokulturen die bienenvölker
sie müssen riesige umwege fliegen um an
die pflanzen zu kommen die sie für ihren
honig benötigen hinzu kommt ein parasit
der 1977 aus asien nach deutschland
eingeschleppt wurde
schuld sind dabei die züchter selbst die
infizierte bienenvölker und königinnen
von asien nach europa geschickt haben
der parasit die varroamilbe setzt sich
als blutsauger an den bienen fest und
schwächt sich schon so und infiziert die
bienen dabei über die offenen wunden mit
viren die sie dann noch weiter schwächen
ganze völker sterben so befallen aus
wenn es kalt wird kommt dann der tod die
niedrigen temperaturen geben den
geschwächten bienenvölkern den rest
verheerend war der letzte
hinter in diesem winter also 2015 sind
rund 30 der deutschen bienenvölker
eingegangen das heißt von den rund
750.000 bienenvölkern haben 225.000 den
winter nicht überstanden
jetzt gibt es nur noch 525.000
bienenvölker in deutschland
die folgen sind kaum absehbar eines ist
klar der honig wird weniger und damit
teurer aber ob sich dieser rückgang der
bienenvölker schon auf zb die obst
ernten auswirken wird kann heute niemand
sagen
es muss also dringend gehandelt werden
gegen die varroa-milbe hilft
ameisensäure zurzeit wird 60-prozentige
eingesetzt die aber nicht immer hilft
deshalb laufen tests mit 80 prozentiger
säure die aber noch nicht zugelassen ist
forscher der ruhr-universität bochum
wollen die milbe mit duftstoffen in die
falle locken und die bayerische
landesanstalt für wein- und gartenbau
hat eine spezielle saat mischung
veitshöchheimer bienenweide mit einer
großen pflanzenvielfalt entwickelt und
die beschränkung für pestizide in europa
die vor zwei jahren von der
eu-kommission verhängt wurden müssen
bestehen bleiben
ich denke dass wir schnell gehandelt
werden muss durch das aussterben der
bienenvölker bedrohen wir die menschheit
ganz konkret hier hätte das aussterben
einer tier hat ganz konkrete und
dramatische folgen für die menschheit
es muss also dringend gehandelt werden
ganz konkret wird die menschheit
übrigens auch durch asteroiden bedroht
was wenige wissen oder realisieren
jedes jahr treffen zwei größere
asteroiden die erde
bisher wurde aber kein größerer schaden
angerichtet weil sie stets in
unbewohntem gebiet einschlugen
alle infos dazu in diesem video
asteroiden bedrohen die erde aktuelle
wissenschafts news im block und in der
app und zwar täglich und das gibt da da
klicken oder unten natürlich alles in
der video beschreibung und was meint ihr
hätten wir früher anfangen müssen die
bienenvölker zu retten was haltet ihr
davon dass in diesem winter 30 prozent
der bienenvölker in deutschland
eingegangen sind
schreibt es
in die kommentare bis dann bleibt dran